only now with the water receding can the
military start the effort to clear the
roads and motorways
in one of germany's worst affected
cities an official sphere as the work
continues more bodies will be discovered
so many people are still missing in
western germany and parts of earthstat
have been cut off for days residents who
were forced to abandon their homes
during the flooding
have seen the staggering images of what
has happened to their neighborhoods
the ground and withered houses washed
away
this video was captured by one homeowner
as she and others escaped the water
on the back of a lorry they were
grateful to have made it out
but the displaced left with little or
nothing and were forced to queue for
handouts of 200 euros
to buy basics this man tells me the
three houses next to his home
collapse all all houses hour
and so at the bottom other other houses
came in the bottom
and did you lose your house did your
house
fall down three houses before there is
others waited as long as they could to
leave before being told it was too
dangerous to stay
somebody knocked at our door and there
was a
precisely not policeman fire brigade man
and he asked us to leave the house
suddenly i thought you
just wanted to know if we're okay or if
you needed help you know
but no we had to leave the state's
premier and the man who aims to be
germany's next chancellor
has visited the city to see the rescue
operation
and to promise support to those affected
here
hundreds of people are willing to drop
everything and help us on the ground
so i want to thank all those volunteers
germany will do everything possible over
the next couple of days to organize the
funds necessary
but it's clear recovery will be long and
costly
homes businesses and livelihoods have
been destroyed and the damage stretches
way beyond this city
and its inhabitants in the german town
of arwyla
the floodwaters overwhelmed homes in
minutes some have returned
glad to be alive but questioning how
they will ever recover
i think it will take months or years to
to
put all so look at the street
it takes a year to
i cannot say anything and the danger has
not yet
passed overnight a damn burst in germany
forcing the residents of this village
to abandon their properties
the situation here is tragic we've had
to evacuate many out of the old people's
home
this is already a disaster and this
morning it's gotten worse
i don't know when it's supposed to end
recovery will be slow
and costly the true scale of this
disaster is yet
to fully emerge michelle clifford sky
news
germany